three topics
which
some of us related to each other
the first and second problems motivated
us to
tackle the third problem they may say
for prediction of antibody antigen
interactions
this program is hardest and today's main
topic
the first topic is about
our support
for sequence analysis of coronavirus
especially for
gca's database
actually this is an easy problem and
the changes we made was not heavy
we have been developing the maft program
for multiple secrets alignment
since
2002
this plot
is
taken from our 20 years old paper
showing
cpu time as
a function of sequence length
for highly similar sequences
slope of this line
these two lines
is around one
which means cpu time is almost linear to
sequence length
but
for divergent sequences
the efficiency is not so high
so most is efficient for globally
arriving closely deviated long sequence
long sequences
such as viruses of closely related
biosynonyms
so this program is must is routinely
used in this area
however
at first we did not expect this
application
global alignments of virus genomes until
we saw many
analyses of coronavirus using mast
after seeing
these applications and receiving some
questions and requests we made
some adjustments specifically for this
application
this product show the number of
citations to math papers
lab is
rapidly increasing
since
around 2020
due to spread of copies 19
and
here is a list
of nature papers related to coronavirus
coronavirus analysis using must
it's nice for us to see the contribution
of our tool
for solving this dr word program
beyond
our original purpose
in this context we recently made some
small modifications to maft
as a response to requests from dr
raphael d in
gs8 today i'd like to explain three
options
for
constructing an msa consisting of
millions of chronovirus genomes
this the
are available
if you register gca's database with an
option to download msas
here is
screenshot
to download the images
before asking us the request
they were using
only a simple object marked
add fragments and deep lengths
first i'd like to explain
simple calculation for msa
they originally used
this option is a combination of three
command line arguments first
the fft algorithm is used
this is enough enabled by default
second
by the add fragment flag
new sequences are added to reference
alignment
in the case of source code 2
the han strain is used as defense
but
by the key length flag in searches uh
in such as at the new sequences uh or
deleted
to keep the lens of sequence and the
length
of alignment
um it has as illustrated in this video
if a new sequence has a deletion new
sequence is shown let
this is deletion in new sequence
such direction is included in resulting
alignment
and represented by gap
such gap
is here
on the other hand
if
new sequence has in such like this
then
the insertion is just deleted
this
strategy works well in most cases but
sometimes this is not convenient because
the the insertions at
the new sequences are always ignored
to avoid this problem raphael d in gsaid
uses a bit complicated procedure like
this
i cannot explain the detail of this
procedure today but
in short
new sequences in
music
cis these insertions are listed up in
advance
next
the sequences with insertions are
aligned to the different sequence
without deleting insertions
unlike the previous right
so the alignments around length gets
longer at this step because of
insertions finally the remaining
sequences are aligned to the alignment
created by the previous step
as a result without ignoring the
insertions and may save millions of
sequences can be calculated in a
reasonable time
this procedure is also convenient
because they need to calculate only
the increment of sequences
unless novel insertions are newly
sampled
the detailed procedure is described in
the readme file in the data
he also asked me for a new option for
codon-based alignment and i nearly
implemented this option next i'd like to
explain this option and
a limitation of this option
i think the usefulness of cotton-based
alignment is clear or obvious in this
example
these are two alignments between uh
strain and new variant
three bases
tac
was inserted in the b variant
at
the nucleotide level
there is no difference in alignment
score between these two alignments
however
the second one can be
translated
to protein more simply
so the second alignment
is more convenient
to return this type of nucleated
alignment considering amino acid
translations i nearly implemented some
option to sub
codon codompos and codon square
however codon-based alignment does not
always return correct alignment in terms
of evolution
these two alignments
are between
the hand strain and
alpha variant
the first star diving
the first argument is quite simple six
bases
t a c a t z g was just deleted protein
translation is a bit complicated because
the position of gap does not correspond
to codon boundary
we see the amino acid alignment in black
background here
three amino acids are unclear and
disarranged
so the artifactor laying is
in this case
each
a uncertain gap saturn and s
on the other hand in the codon-based
alignment this gap
does not break
codon boundary as a result amino acid
alignment is clearer
alpha variant has just two amino acid
deletion
hb however
the evolutionary event behind this
codonvest alignment
is a bit complicated
two events are necessary g a t gtc was
deleted and
a was
substituted with c
if accepting this nucleotide alignment
considering this change occurred in a
very short period of time the first
scenario is more likely
this problem is clearer in another case
the comparison between uh strain and
omicron strain
usually the omicron variant is described
to have
g
142 d
and a deletion at the next three sites
140
to 5.
this notation is a bit confusing no not
completely incorrect but a bit confusing
i explained it
at the nucleotide level
the change in this region can be very
simple
just one deletion
as in this arrangement
the origin of amino acid d aspartic acid
is easy to understand this aspartic acid
was generated by a concatenation of
originally different codons
here and here here going in plus adenine
cytosine
these bases were originally used to code
amino acid glycine and tyrosine in
strain
rice and tiles
firstly
so this change was not a point mutation
but a deletion concatenation of codon
on the other hand
using codon-based alignment two
different proteins and two different
protein alignments are possible
here and here
in this arrangement
body entire thing
piracy was deleted and gracie was
substituted by d
this is the same as standard notation
however this codon-based alignment
corresponding codon-based alignment
requires a bit complicated change at the
nucleotide level the changes are two
transversion from glanin to adenine and
thymine to cytosine and deletion of 12
pieces
the same problem occurs in
third alignment too
i mean amino acid alignment is simple
but
it requires complicated changes at the
nuclear level considering these points
the first alignment is simpler and
more likely
than the last two in this case
under this scenario the notation g 100
to d are a bit inaccurate or confusing
it can be misunderstood that
g was substituted with d
more precisely
the aspartic acid was generated from a
concatenation of split codon not a
substitution
based on this consideration they decided
to provide both options codon-based
alignment and
simple nucleotide based alignment
in total four
available
four msas are available in their site i
hope this data is widely used and helps
many studies on virus
the second topic is revolutionary
analysis of virus we published in the
last year 2021 possible adaptive
resolution in details of south korea
effect infecting but
i will skip this part because
time is not enough
here's our paper our conclusion is that
a relative subscribe to infecting
non-human hosts would have useful
information to clarify the mechanism of
infection
and probably
there was we concluded probably there
was adaptive evaluation in outer groups
but and fungaling and such
relatives of south korea infecting butt
and pancreas
this is
and
we
i will move to the last story
in essen three
we therefore predict predicting
anti-antibody interactions
we are happy to see that most was used
for analysis of virus
as in the first topic in this talk but
i'm looking for other important problems
for which most is not used yet
one of such problem is structure
prediction of proteins
recently alfa ford program by deepmind
achieved a great improvement in protein
structure prediction
this program can also be used to
predict structure of protein complex
this year new option especially for
complex prediction was released this
option is called alpha ford martimer
according to their paper
alpha ford maritima
also achieved
a
surprising improvement over
conventional method here is a
conventional method and
performance of alpha for the multimeter
is shown here
the vertical axis is doctor score and i
will omit the explanation of the q
square
according to the arrangement the
performance was
improved from
almost
incorrect
to
around medium
average however
there seemed to be a consensus that
antibody and gain interaction is
difficult to predict
even for alpha for the multimer
the preprint of alpha for the martina
noted that
alpha for the multima
is
generally not able to predict binding of
antibodies and this is an area for
future work
he confirmed this result using some
examples
this calculation was done by
done by a doctor student
in our laboratory
in this table each line shows
an antigen antibody complex with known
structure of receptor binding domain
of spike protein from covet 19.
and
about half
of these cases
was successfully predicted by alphabet
maritime but
the meaning was
not successful
this program are relatively easy because
only the receptor binding domain was
extracted from running learning or for
the multiple this result is more
realistic
and difficult cases projects
collected from wide range of antigens
other than coronavirus
only three cases out of 25 hot medium or
acceptable adjustment and the prediction
was incorrect in many other cases
the difficulty is easy to understand
in many
protein protein interactions the
evolutionary relationship is expected
to be like this ideally
in both protein 1 and protein 2
the binding
sites should be more conserved than
other sites
as there is a functional constraint to
keep the interaction
even if a change occurs in this area
a compensatory change can occur around
that change
probably such information can be
included in training of world or other
prediction programs
in antigua antibody interactions the
relationship between sequence hormones
are considerably different from usual
ones
the relationship is kind of aggressive
or unfriendly for example
antigens sometimes escape
from
antibody
also even for the same pair of antigen
and antibody different and
different epitopes in an antigen can be
recognized by different
antibodies
finally antibody can bind entirely
different antennas
these antibodies are all homogenous
nevertheless
antigens are also hormones
even though they have different or no
epitopes so mss
of homologous hormones are calculated
and used for prediction
but
such msa are confusing in terms of
information on interactions
the images can be mixed of antibodies
that bind different antigens and mixture
of antennas with different or no
epitopes
a typical case was
spike protein in non-human
infecting non-human hearts hosts
based on this consideration it's easy to
explain by the prediction of
is difficult
first
homologous sequences are generally used
for predicting interactions this is
reasonable for many cases
those columns share the same interaction
and there is functional constraint to
keep the function
of interaction however
this strategy is not expected to work
well for anti-gay antibody interactions
so it's not easy to solve this problem
but i'd like to briefly discuss what we
are trying and planning but i cannot
present good solution yet a key is to
use a set of antibodies that bind the
same f-stop
instead of a large set of antibodies
for this purpose we are planning to use
a new database called
chrome being built in our laboratory
this database works simply
a number of antibody sequences
are stored as shown in this diagram
then you give an antibody thickness of
probe
the
similar antibodies in terms of cdrs are
returned
this program only check
cydia
complementarity determining region
as a results
asset of antibody sequences that is that
expected to
bind similar antigen is corrected
is corrected
unfortunately it's not easy to clearly
distinguish antibodies that bind on
epitope from antibodies that do not bind
the laptop
this data is taken from preprint using
interchrome
this preprint is by
indra is amanda and co-authors in osaka
university
they have experimental data that
that was sampled from healthy donors and
patients of cobit 19.
also it's known which antibody blind and
epitope and which antibody do not bind
that eptop
and
this is
known in the data experimentally
using this data an
experimental validation of interchronics
possible
in this broad
antibodies
in pink
bind
same laptop as the probe and
green antibodies do not bind that laptop
the vertical axis is a sequence identity
to the probe
calculated from only the
complementarity determining vision
so it's naively expected that green
points and pink points clearly separate
from each other indeed
there is such a thing there is such a
tendency pink points tend to have a
higher sequence identity
around here
green points
however this standard is not strong
green points and pink points do not
separate clearly so the sequence
identity at cdrs
should be used useful to
to some extent but more data not only
cdrs
is necessary to clearly differentiate
by binders from non-binders
using interchronic other tools
especially for antibodies we are trying
to collect a better set of sequences
expect expecting that msa of such
sequences
should be useful for prediction of
antibody and interactions
the last part
is collaboration with darussandre
chi-chan shu sun ding-di and hendra is
samut
in osaka university
thank you for your attention
any questions before we break for lunch
your
these variants are you know we have a
lot of data on you know
um
[Music]
[Music]
effectivity is another problem and
probably
a difficult problem
i have not tried
any other questions
all right uh i have a question on the
alpha fool for antibody anti-audience
gen prediction
so the solution um you proposed using
inter clone was
essentially
trying to subset
the homologues to just the antibodies
that bind
a specific epitope of a specific antigen
yes yeah i expect that should work
better than the
normal
right
and but in the case of a
new antibody and antigen you would need
to know for
a given sequence
what homologs bind to the same epitope
and
antigen if the
if the
antibodies
binding same
hormones
uh
exist in
database but does not recognize
then in such case i expect
this
our proposal
can
improve the prediction
i see so so you will need to have
homologs that
do bind this the same epitope yeah and
finding it is the difficult part it
seems like
to differentiate it between
two other antibodies that might bind the
same antigen but different epidurals
but that step is also difficult
we
have not succeeded in clearly
differentiated
the binder and non-binders
yes this is
this is very
this seems to be very difficult for me
but we are trying to solve i think thank
you
professor cato thank you so much for
your talk i have a slightly off topic
question
so in the beginning of your talk you
said it was possible to do
the multiple sequence alignment at the
of soros coveted
sequences these are longer than typical
gene sequences but they're not
necessarily as long as some genomes so
my question for you is
um
is there a possibility that we can use
your maf software to do
multiple whole genome alignment as long
as there's no
rearrangements do you think that's
feasible
genome rearrangement is excluded from
mass calculation so unfortunately
this is not
it's not possible to directly apply
genome
alignment
so it's necessary to
split
array and rearrange the part and
if the
part without the arrangement is a pass
by ma pass to maps then it may be useful
but it cannot be directly applied to the
genome
general alignment
okay so let's thank professor carter
again
[Applause]
lunch outside here
but there are many places around here
that are actually quite nice
oh
[Music]
[Music]
it's